Maz Vidale which is similar amazing back
street fighting in Miami with Kimbo it
then fighting professionally forever and
on the highest level you know that
American Top Team yeah but his to his
point
Mazal all started with Kimmel's in this
backyard fighting yeah and was on but he
was 17 yeah
Oh was he he was 17 and 14 who's like
the Nick Cannon yes yeah and then he
went to it you know they went to camp
and did it right yeah I knew I when he
left I remember I remember when he
fought Wonder Boy and he lost that split
decision Mazda doll and I was like oh
that guy's pretty good yeah he does he's
I don't know he always said he always on
malice he always loses to clothes toys
split decisions it's gonna be
interesting to see how what kind of
numbers they get taken the yes husband
all that bad [ __ ] I can't wait I
can't wait either if you're not really
[ __ ]
no they knocked each other similar those
guys in a lot of ways yeah I would have
liked to see well I mean I my pick is
Mazda Orleans fight but but to see Mazda
I'll fight someone like Nick Diaz who's
a bigger version of Nate and probably
made [ __ ] Big Nate one anyone fight
or two ranks bigger next big well yeah
Nick's Baker yeah
but he's fighting Nate yeah I know my
fault Nate the perfect match yeah Nick's
way bit why don't you think Nick is too
big for must be normal
Nick face it seventy miles but now it's
been eight one else about fighter 2
right yeah yeah name ten Nate's a stuff
that's weird be yeah no that's a great
matchup
I just seems a better matchup use Nate
fought at 55 yeah that's true
I don't know that's strange I noticed
wat Nathan EB though this is it it's to
that Nick is just done right he doesn't
he's no more fighting friend ma ones
last time we fought fraud second right
you think what Gregor's ever come back I
don't think so I don't know but I I
don't know why I come back he's got it
yeah I mean he'd have his hands full
what's it gonna do I mean when you're
that is it risky to you know yeah I
don't know why you would it's just crazy
to think he hasn't won in like three
years talking about it well what do you
think it's tough for him are these
tougher for him yeah that would be the
thing to get him back he's coming off
those losses mm-hmm why he doesn't want
to go out like that
I mean figure he lose
to the boxing greatest boxer of all time
that's my answer to the one of the
greatest UFC fighters of all time it's
like you didn't lose the Joe Schmo no
let's not get you met you know not like
Roy Jones no Mike who's in the you know
Igor I'm Russian in Russia but give him
starts and then later that week doing
HBO broadcasting like no dude just stop
me on his words like this academic or
Bernard Hopkins yeah Hopkins he stopped
after he got beat up by that
construction worker from Long Island no
you didn't get beat up hold up yeah yeah
and got concussed with his head hitting
on the ground yeah and and really spent
most of his career not even getting hurt
but then he was like you know what I'm
[ __ ] out Roy get knocked down begging
now let's keep going but it's also like
goes back to the Jason I remember Jason
Kidd was on the Dallas Mavericks and he
was 41 the title is how you plan so well
at your age he goes it's not the games
that make you old it's what you do in
between the games yeah someone like
Bernard Hopkins didn't drink didn't
party got up there I ran mastermind you
know he his body didn't have the wear
and tear even with Mayweather Mayweather
goes out he didn't drink those guys the
water
there's also yeah he's a total monk that
way now those guys are also fight in
such a defensive way like if you
actually look at like Hopkins or they
not they didn't take a lot of shots to
the head
you don't really don't right there just
really defensive fighters in comparison
to a lot of other guys so you know I
mean that's who you think who you think
wins between uh well hopefully all
happened to win Spence and Crawford you
not see that for a while brother there's
just two different divisions so it's
hard to get them together but I'm you
know I was super impressed I was so
impressed with Shawn Porter and if he
had knocked Shawn Porter down mm-hmm
with that letting that last round I
think the fight would have been a draw
so I could also just nasty man fight a
[ __ ] shows you how good he is but
Earl Spence is he just gets it done I
don't know I don't know what do you
think about that um
Crawford be a tough one for him it would
be a tough one yeah because in Crawford
be slightly favored in that one yeah
I've never seen Crawford he just doesn't
fight the top guys you know
yeah I'd never even seen him remotely in
trouble no I start just doing so crafty
changes nothing strategy all the time
every time I go to Omaha as III go in on
I'm pretty hard and then he doesn't come
the shows but it gets back to me through
like DMS oh really dude I said every
time he gets tired he'd be thinking a
child-support like uh uh win this round
he likes over all those kids are sitting
there goes I got this how many kids do
you have six I'd say he's gotta use his
crane Omaha what do you and what what in
the what the one sons us like the best
wrestler in the state oh really
you got about yes stud dude yeah I hope
he did what he did my show yeah I'd be
nice if we did the if him and Spence
Papa and I'd be a great fight that's
what's wrong with boxing man yeah there
is a good thing you have seen matchups
yeah you get there you get the best guys
and they fight each other yeah UFC don't
mess around you're gonna get it at all
you're gonna get it eating a great fight
great fighters wouldn't you you've had
two fights anything neither throw em
with some duties yeah but your if you
can lose one and you still good boxing
you lose you're kind of [ __ ] man yeah
thanks they're back well unless you get
a performance like Porter but the thing
about it you can't lose two in a row
can't lose dinero but yeah boxing's
weird man but seem like you're not
getting Anthony and Josh for a night in
fury and I can wilder like this the
heavyweights so fun right now Joshua's
not gonna fight Wilder I mean he's gotta
fight Ruiz first but well they both have
fights come up so you get we don't allow
to fight or cease no joke November 23rd
nightmare your boxing fan yeah that guy
heard him the first fight I hurt him bad
and I said this and Showtime but you
know I just I take that fight doesn't
makes it's so stupid to do it's the risk
isn't worth the reward I have no idea
why they're doing it look old Fury's
doing the only thing I would say is
Ortiz is older he's about 70 and the
Mattathias [ __ ] it doesn't matter since
Ortiz lost a Wilder he's got on a tear
just [ __ ] dudes up yeah then waters
like yeah let's run that back thing
alright and you got this guaranteed
fight in February against fury fury won
his match barely right
so now you're gonna fight Ortiz also no
one cares no one watches Ortiz yeah so
it's like why this not worth it you
risked it cuz he loses you not getting
fear
Ortiz reminds me of IKEA bûche before he
got locked up yeah
Ike was annihilating people never really
got hurt and then I mean obviously
Wilder heard Ortiz but I but before that
Seder was down like I mean yeah he
knocked him down the tenth night before
that Wilder was probably down seven rat
like he was he going out he got stunned
a couple times
oh that's the fighter Ikey bûche that
nobody talks about that was was was
knocking everybody out nobody want to
fight him okay I remember him he got he
got locked up like yeah he wasn't all
together
was he undefeated I think he was
undefeated he was a Nigerian said I have
the chicken man yeah he was undefeated
nobody talks about that dude he was
amazing
beat to uh destroy him be Chris bird
yeah [ __ ] dudes up how many knockouts
he have 15 and I bet you all his
decisions were like knocked out five of
your brothers what do you get locked up
for Vegas fractional assaults
imprisonment Mirage Hotel escort service
once enters room 21 year-old said she
claimed attacked her in the walk-in
closet demand to be paid up front but
she barricaded himself in the bathroom
Oh interesting he wasn't all there but I
remember Chris bird he destroyed crisper
how long do you locked up for 2003 20
years for taking him out in 2020 he came
out pretty soon held until September
29th interesting cuz he that raper does
it he phoned a escort service 21-year
old went to his room said she was there
to strip she claimed a Bochy attacked
her in the walking closet after she
demanded to be paid up front
okay well attacked there like that's
pretty loose work you know there's what
goes with the tagged hmm it was really
locked up for 20 years so he probably
was not good I mean he wasn't it wasn't
all there upstairs he was all but that
guy we just I just remember thinking
this is the guy nobody's gonna want to
fight
and then I'll say he was not arrested
though it said mm-hmm tough tough gig
all right I was really remind me a lot
of arrested he's a problem man
so I wouldn't fight l7 tickets doesn't
talk in a [ __ ] no one knows who he is
nightmare
yeah such a stupid fight yeah but the
wait we'd be on t talks and the way he
he thinks is like his team thinks they
saw something where they can take
advantage of him and get him out of
there under six but when he talks he's
like he's got a he's got a daughter he
needs to take care of you just wonder is
it like I'm trying out a you tell you
time out waters got the special needs
daughter but yeah Ortiz had a daughter
too
yeah something's going on yeah so I
remember water going new this is you
know now he can take care of his kids
off this fight he just makes you wonder
was something going on like a wink-wink
do behind closed door let's get let's
get this guy a take a dive I'm not
saying take a dive that's not that idea
that to me makes no sense that's get
this yeah it's not a bad that's really
not a battle show times not part of it
first first flight of Wilders then I'm
part of we're good okay Bri models not
worth it to pay Wilder all this money
what will he make for that what do we
know I mean they paid him 20 something
million to [ __ ] starch Brazil in the
first round this is healers in Alabama
which is like 80 million in LA yeah
that's fifty hundred thousand yeah yeah
lake house there is a house in the
Atlanta to not the most expensive places
to live hey how many kids he the same
woman for a long time I know he has one
and then he has to his wifey now yeah
they're great men yeah I like the odd
thing he's a fun interviewer yeah you
know you're like I don't know if that
made any sense you know sometimes I say
a word that did they just like this
started at 20 start boxing at 20 years
old Oh later 24 yeah it was just an
athlete years later I'm crazy in Alabama
Nike started at Kronk and Detroit know
started in Alabama trainers for I never
trained anybody else it had a world
title look at that [ __ ] they say anybody
what's a heavy Alice says he hit so hard
that he hit you in the head your
colles fracture well there's a lot
people can attest so water has eight
children Oh what why you go hey another
okay then he's got eight kids that's why
it's fine Ortiz okay eight children I
didn't know that okay well holy cow
yeah even Marquez is going that's a lot
every Latino fighters I know more what
is that like eight kids all right plus a
nuts bro
great Congrats his pull out game is not
you out of ten percenter boxing it's a
Kherson what seven kids how no it's
there Martino Kumar D for the oh yeah
yeah kids with like nine different but
Philip Rivers is Mormon oh is that what
I did last nuts its same girl okay dude
come already has like nine different
baby mamas fourteen kids oh I don't want
that stress yeah yeah dad your kids so
you got a bunch of fatherless kids
really is what's going on that's awesome
that's good for a kid good job camarda
you [ __ ] dummy he's [ __ ] no we
don't know that we don't ninety four
women you're an [ __ ] oh because you
know why you're an [ __ ] you can't you
can't be there for your kids you're an
[ __ ] and it's called fat it's called
fatherless kids he follows me on
instagram do you [ __ ] have you - man
[ __ ] any of these guys any these guys
who have that many kids from baller
because you can't bottle I'm gonna get
you pregnant guys I have my kid and I'll
see you kid pricier get the [ __ ] out of
here no I don't know the visitation
rights of kamar D but Tommy Tommy oh hey
go back to the upper singer yeah yeah
yeah yeah watch your tongue oh good
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
[Laughter]